so this Camp I Wrestled a lot yeah
that's so when I was telling arrows I I
know something you just don't I know how
to wrestle
and people don't know I really know how
to wrestle I couldn't use it as much as
I wanted to because a he's he's done
what I do against the fans good take
that defense you pick him up he just
sticks his toes on the floor you'll be
amazed how powerful your toes can just
be just being on the floor you can't get
taken down and also my leg was
compromised by him can you explain that
first of all two things one I thought
you were very uh I thought it was very
well handled you giving him credit for
compromising a leg a lot of people in
the post conference will go and they'll
say oh my leg was [ __ ] up and that's
why it happened he [ __ ] it up I [ __ ]
his leg up too he just did it
I think he did it worse short term
because I'm walking you saw me [ __ ]
walking and [ __ ] yeah I bet you his is
probably still sore right now yeah but
mine he hit the perineal nerve what is
that so I've seen it happen earlier on
and years ago with Michael Chandler
crude also that guy you know yeah yeah
that's what happened to him that's right
it did I remember with um Hill
right it did happen when his [ __ ] was oh
yeah I remember it bro so yeah um and
also sahuto as well what happened to him
but I remember
um when it happened to me it might have
been the second kick he landed and my
leg just went it was fine I just felt
the the nerve like shoot up and I was
like okay that's weird
um but then throughout the fight it
started to like you know when you're
walking and you're just like you have
heavy feet and you just dragging it just
drags on the floor it felt like that
every like maybe 10-15 seconds I'll be
moving and just like my my toes just
catch the ground you know what I mean so
I kept on tripping I'm just like oh [ __ ]
okay this is annoying but I stayed
focused I stayed focused the whole time
so this happened the first round you hit
it yeah first it happens yeah I was fine
I was moving around but then the longer
the fight went
and the more leg kicks he landed the
worse it got it did seem like maybe you
were shuffling your feet and switching
up stances a little bit less is that why
ah probably yeah because
I normally switch way more I would have
been switching I wanted to say stop for
a little bit more because my body kick
was Landing yeah
um my straight left was Landing
um what else my jab was Landing as well
from Orthodox everything was [ __ ]
Landing yeah
everything was Landing I will say this
you ate a head kick yeah
what oh wait oh it didn't it didn't land
I thought it landed online there's one I
saw a picture of this but then there's
one where I think I had my hand up and
it hit me when you went like this
afterwards you went that's this is what
I do bro
obviously everybody's seeing this guy
and he's you know doing damage and you
see a kick like that and then you eat
that one yeah and were you were you I
know it's weird to even have this
conversation were you surprised about
power
nah I like so I made the agreement with
myself before this fight like yo this is
gonna be bloody that's why I had that
whole saw theme throughout Camp I
haven't even watched the movie in the
soil one in the years but I've just I
don't know what uh something happened
maybe chainsaw man the anime who put me
onto that yeah that's right yeah yeah
that's right so chainsaw man I watched
that
um but funny enough as I watched that I
already had the salt theme like played
out through the camera and then I was
just like this is I made the agreement
this is going to be one of those fights
like gasoline I'm going in there to go
five rounds and get bloody get Dusty and
I knew we were both going to bleed I
knew I was gonna drive into deep water
and I was I wanted to make sure he
couldn't swim but again this guy is a
comeback kid yeah same way last time
that's the thing it's like same way as
last time I had him in the first people
didn't watch that whole fight the
kickboxing fight they were referencing
the reporters yeah after my last last
fight I had to tell them like look watch
your homework yeah yeah and I I asked
him it's like how many of you guys watch
the fight I think like five people to
handle I'm like exactly and here you all
talking all this [ __ ] and you ain't even
watch the fight yet yeah you're supposed
to be journalists they could have
stopped that fight
oh no the referee saved him that's what
I'm saying the referee saved them
definitely and gave him like a [ __ ]
15 count you know what I mean yeah
because it's a Brazil so oh yeah a
little home Corvette you know okay fair
enough so you're in there you're feeling
it you don't feel the power that crazy
you're feeling super comfortable when
you touched me you felt it it was not
like I felt it but it wasn't like I felt
scarier he's knocked me out before
obviously but I felt scarier like and if
an unboxing one of my boxing fights was
the one where he hit me and it felt like
two by four hit me in the face I was
like oh
don't get hit by that again this fight
wasn't like that
I was willing to I was not willing to
take damage but I was willing to be in
the fire yeah you were willing to trade
you looked like yeah like because you
were stepping in yeah yeah and then
there was a moment
I don't know man there was a moment
where when you started taking him down
and you were what is it the third round
yeah third round took him down when the
wrestling and first let me tell you
something in the crowd in that moment
nobody expects you to dominate wrestling
I'm just going to be honest that's not
the expectation myself included but when
we see and he continued trying to get up
you leaning on bring him back down using
all these different legs draining his
enthusiasm
drain the enthusiasm so and also for me
people don't understand the the kick
where you lift up
shout out to GSP I remember like in that
moment I was just like do the GSP and
get right back in there yeah I wish I
had more time to work I wish I had more
time to work but again good defense he's
durable he's tough but when I had him
down he couldn't get away from me like
the shackles
um I had the they call it the dagestani
handcuff inshallah you know the one who
told them but then I have my own way I
get the Cross grip and I beat him up and
I could just transfer because bro he
couldn't get it feel this yeah yeah try
and get away that well that's good yeah
no just get away just get away
yeah I'll just hold his control it's
like controlling my hands making sure I
know where his hands is I was trying to
step in with the elbow but then
sometimes he would flare his which would
make me hesitate but I I missed a couple
I got a couple I'm pretty sure but I
missed a couple but just controlling the
hands just so you know where his hands
is because those are his main weapons he
can still throw kicks and stuff but then
I knew how to check those if I control
the hands I can just worry about the
bottom half check them step back
whatever I need to do yeah okay so then
take us through fifth round fifth round
so fifth round
um by the way end of the fourth yeah it
looks like he's gassed it was it looked
like he didn't want anything it's the
same thing it's the same last time when
I fought him in kickboxing it's the same
thing I whooped his ass in the second
round first round was in a draw like he
said I whipped his ass clean second
round I hope that that's even worse and
third round
he just got Gusto he just got Gusty he
recovered he's a comeback kid he
recovers so well Gotta Give him credit
yeah and then um yeah this time again
and I heard the speech today that his
Corner gave him and it was a beautiful
speech you know like his corner just
gave him this [ __ ] motivating speech
but I was like okay you have to you
can't you know you have to be in this
you have to focus and I was but my leg
wasn't focused right and it's a great
it's a great game plan for men because
of what I have that footwork you can't
you can't touch me if I don't let you
yeah so what invest early
and he didn't hit the nerve perfect I
don't think that was the plan maybe that
was the plan was just to dead in the leg
or whatever but he hit the legs early
and then that way my wheels weren't
working so if my wheels aren't working
I'm a stationary Target I'm easy to hit
so in the fifth round you feel the
wheels aren't turning you feel him come
out with way more aggression than the
end of the fourth where you're stalking
him at the end of the fourth he's
backing up I wanted to take him down the
fifth but then again with this
compromise you could shoot yeah yeah I
was about to double leg or single leg
and drag him down or run the pipe but it
wasn't I felt like it didn't have the
same month also
breaking news
I was going to pull out of this fight
early on no last time I fought in New
York 230 I was gonna pull out of that
fight with three weeks left but then um
with Brunson because my knee dissed me
that time but then I had cortisone
injection I took a whole five days off
nothing no no nothing five days off and
then it just got better I came over to
MSG and I dominated this time is from
the last fight with Cannon near I hurt
my um PCL yep and that's the thing that
keeps your knee from going backwards
yeah and um yeah early in Camp it had
some problems so there was a bit how
many weeks maybe like no
three three weeks I just did boxing
boxing and grappling no kicking so
sparring I'll just put boxing gloves on
and I'll spot my teammates I'll tell
them no kicks just so they give this a
chance to heal and it healed quite well
I was taking eventually at towards the
end of camp or towards like halfway I
was taking electrics from Carlos
checking them he's the hardest kicker in
the gym yeah but um yeah so I was gonna
pull out early on but I was like nah I
want to get this done because I I'm a I
think man yeah I'm a prideful man I'll
be damned if people say I'm a [ __ ]
I'm scared of this guy because I know
I'm not yeah I knew I wanted to fight I
knew I wanted to fight also make a point
to fight three times this year as a
champion I wanted to make a point
because every time you fight bro it's
like you you put the [ __ ] on the line
and
I'm not going to be this guy who just
parades because
you know when you get the belt you fight
once a year
then you you have [ __ ] how many
months of just you know I'm the Champion
and then you can just have that that
long reign as a champion oh then he's
been champ for this long nah I wanna
[ __ ] I'm young right now yeah I'm
healthy you want to eat I want to eat
I'm fresh I want to make money you know
so yeah I put it on the line and I want
to make sure to fight three times so I'm
glad I did I'm glad I did an MSG and I'm
glad they're with my teammates as well
and brought the whole Squad with me like
it's the whole thing is a beautiful yeah
beautiful story for us